E
ONES THAT KA CARRIED OUT THIS
ATTACK.
>> MAU, KEEP US UPDATED.
>>> JOINING US NOW THE WHITE
HOUSE'S NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL SPOKESMAN JOHN KIRBY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THIS
MORNING.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO RUSSIA
CLAIMING THAT IT'S ACTUALLY
WASHINGTON BEHIND THIS DRONE
ATTACK SAYING ESSENTIALLY THEY
TELL KYIV WHAT TO DO?
>> THERE IS A WORD THAT COMES TO
MIND THAT I AM NOT APPROPRIATE
TO USE ON NATIONAL TV.
I WOULD JUST TELL YOU MR. PESKOV
IS LYING.
IT'S A LUDICROUS CLAIM.
THE UNITED STATES HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THIS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
HERE, KAITLIN.
I CAN ASSURE YOU, THE UNITED
STATES HAD NO ROLE IN IT
WHATSOEVER.
AGAIN JUST TO BE CLEAR, AND I
THINK YOU COVERED THIS AT THE
BEGINNING, WE NEITHER ENCOURAGE
NOR ENABLE UKRAINE TO STRIKE
OUTSIDE UKRAINE'S BORDERS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY INFORMATION
THAT MIGHT INDICATE WHO WAS
BEHIND?
>> NO, WE DON'T.
WE REALLY DON'T.
WE ARE TRYING TO LEARN ABOUT
THIS BEST WE CAN, BUT WE
HONESTLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
I THINK HERE IS ANOTHER THING
THAT HAPPENED, POPPY.
IN JUST THE LAST 48 HOURS OR SO,
MR. PUTIN HAS CONTINUED TO RAIN
DOWN ON UKRAINE CRUISE MISSILES
AND DRONES.
YESTERDAY KILLED 27 INNOCENT
CIVILIANS IN A RESIDENTIAL
COMPLEXION THAT THEY HIT, LIKELY
INTENTIONALLY.
THAT'S ALSO HAPPENING.
>> ARE YOU SAYING THAT YOU THINK
THIS IS A PRETEXT BY RUSSIA FOR
THOSE ACTIONS?
>> NO, I DON'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT AS IF -- JUST, YOU
KNOW, BACK UP.
EVEN LONGER THAN 48 HOURS AGO,
HE -- OVER THE COURSE OF THE
WEEKEND, MR. PUTIN WAS FLYING
CRUISE MISSILES AND DRONES
HITTING CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TARGETS THROUGHOUT UKRAINE.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE IS LOOKING FOR
AN EXCUSE TO FIND WAYS TO KILL
INNOCENT UKRAINIANS.
>> GIVEN THAT, DO YOU SEE PUTIN
AS A LAWFUL AND LEGITIMATE
MILITARY TARGET?
>> LOOK, WE DON'T FAVOR, WE
DON'T ENENDORSE STRIKES ON
INDIVIDUAL LEADERS.
MR. PUTIN IS THE AGGRESSOR HERE.
HIS FORCES ARE IN UKRAINE
ILLEGALLY AND IN AN UNPROVOKED
WAY.
IF HE WANTS TO END THIS WAR, IF
HE REALLY WANTS TO SEE SECURITY
THERE ON THE CONTINENT, HE COULD
HAVE HIS TROOPS PULL OUT OF
UKRAINE NOW AND END THIS THING
ALL TOGETHER.
>> YOU DON'T FAVOR IT, DON'T
ENDORSE IT, BUT IS IT LAWFUL,
WOULD IT BE LEGITIMATE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S USEFUL TO
GET INTO A LEGAL DISCUSSION
HERE.
WE DON'T ENDORSE, WE DON'T
ENCOURAGE, WE DON'T SUPPORT
ATTACKS ON INDIVIDUAL LEADERS.
>> NOTABLE TO HEAR YOU SAY THAT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT WE ARE HEARING FROM NATO
LEADERS.
THE ASSIST SECRETARY GENERAL FOR
NATO THIS MORNING, JOHN KIRBY,
IS SAYING THAT THEY ARE -- THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT RISKS THAT RUSSIA
COULD PURSUE SABOTAGE TO DISRUPT
WESTERN LIFE, GAIN LEVERAGE
AGAINST THOSE NATIONS PROVIDING
SUPPORT TO UKRAINE.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT CONCERN
THAT RUSSIA IS TARGETING NATO'S
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NAVAL
SYSTEMS, EVEN UNDERSEA CABLES,
ET CETERA, AS A WAY TO FIGHT
THIS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN MINDFUL OF THAT
AND WATCHING AS BEST WE CAN
SINCE ALMOST THE BEGINNING OF
THE WAR, POPPY.
I MEAN, THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE UNITED STATES
THROUGH PRESIDENT BIDEN MOVED SO
FAST AND SO DECISIVELY TO SHORE
UP OUR NATO DEFENSES ON THE
EASTERN FLANK.
WE ARE WATCHING THIS VERY, VERY
CLOSELY.
I AM NOT AWARE OF INTELLIGENCE
OR INFORMATION THAT WOULD LEAD
US TO BELIEVE THAT'S ABOUT TO
HAPPEN.
BUT WE ARE CERTAINLY MONITORING
THIS AS BEST WE CAN.
IT'S NOT, YOU KNOW, JUST
SEPARATE AND DISTINCT FROM THAT
REPORTING, IT'S NOT AS IF MR.
PUTIN HASN'T ALREADY WEAPONIZED
ENERGY BY THE WAY HE TRIED TO
SELL OIL WELL ABOVE MARKET
PRICES AND HOLD BACK THE SUPPLY
TO TRY TO COERCE THE
INTERNATIONAL MARKET.
NOT LIKE HE HASN'T WEAPONIZED
FOOD.
HE HAS DONE THAT, TOO.
THIS IS PART OF A RUSSIAN
PLAYBOOK.
I DON'T HAVE ANY INDICATIONS OR
HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING.
>> YOU SAID THAT THE U.S. DOES
NOT ENCOURAGE ATTACKS OR ENDORSE
THEM ON OTHER WORLD LEADERS.
WE KNOW FROM LEAKED DOCUMENTS
THE U.S. ENCOURAGED UKRAINE NOT
TO ATTACK RUSSIA ON THE
ANNIVERSARY OF RUSSIA'S INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID THE
WHITE HOUSE NEVER CALLED HIM
ABOUT THAT LEAK.
WHY NO?
>> I CAN TELL YOU FOR SURE THAT
AS THESE DOCUMENTS STARTED TO
GET OUT INTO THE PUBLIC, WE HAD
MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS WITH
HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS IN
UKRAINE, AS YOU WOULD EXPECT WE
WOULD.
FRANKLY, WITH OTHER COUNTRIES AS
WELL THAT WERE AFFECTED BY THESE
LEAKS.
AND SO WE DID COMMUNICATE WITH
UKRAINE.
AGAIN VARIOUS LEVELS, VARIOUS
AGENCIES AND VARIOUS OFFICIALS
TO LET THEM KNOW WHAT WAS GOING
ON AND PROMISE WE'D KEEP THEM
INFORMED.
>> WE HAVE BEEN HEARING A LOT
FROM THE U.S. ABOUT WHEN THIS
EXPECTED COUNTEROFFENSIVE IS
GOING TO START.
WHAT'S THE LATEST ASSESSMENT IN
THE U.S. INTELLIGENCE VIEW OF
WHEN THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN AND
HOW MUCH POTENTIAL LAND UKRAINE
COULD RETAKE?
>> I AM NOT GOING TO GET AHEAD
OF UKRAINIAN PLANS HERE.
THIS WOULD BE THE WORST PLACE IN
THE WORLD TO TRY TO DIVULGE THAT
EVEN IF WE HAD THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
THIS IS GOING TO BE UP THE
UKRAINIANS TO DECIDE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
HE GETS TO DECIDE WHERE HIS
MILITARY OPERATES AND WHEN AND
IN WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO I'LL LEAVE IT TO THE
UKRAINIANS TO SPEAK TO WHATEVER
FUTURE OPERATIONS THEY MIGHT OR
MIGHT NOT CONDUCT.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU, KAITLIN, IS
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHEN OR WHERE
AND WHAT UNITS HE DECIDES TO USE
TO CONDUCT OFFENSIVE OPERATIONS
INSIDE HIS COUNTRY, HE'S GOT
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING HE NEEDS
TO DO THAT COMING IN THE WEEKS
AND MONTHS AHEAD.
WE HAVE PROVIDED ANOTHER
SECURITY PACKAGE YESTERDAY OF
SOME $300 MILLION, AMMUNITION,
ARTILLERY PIECES AS WELL AS
BREACHING EQUIPMENT AND
LOGISTICS AND SUSTAINMENT
VEHICLES.
HE HAS ABOUT 98% OF EVERYTHING
HIS FORCES SAY THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT OFFENSIVE
OPERATIONS IN THE SPRING, IN THE
WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD, AND
THAT'S NOT JUST COMING FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S COMING FROM ALLIED AND
PARTNERED NATIONS ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
W
IF THEY STEP OFF, THEY DO SO
READY.
THE OTHER THING, KAITLIN, THAT
OFTEN GETS LOST IS THE TRAINING
WE HAVE DONE.
WE HAVE TRAINED MULTIPLE
BRIGADES OF UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS
OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY OVER THE
LAST FEW MONTHS TO GET THEM
SCHOOLED UP ON SOMETHING WE CALL
COMBINED ARMS MANEUVER, WHICH IS
THE KIND OF INTERNATIONAL
MONETARY FUND INTEGRATED WAR
FIGHTING THEY NEED.
SO THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
TRAINING.
A LOT OF MATERIAL DALLAS.
A LOT OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE
EFFORTS THAT THEY ARE READY AND
IT WILL BE UP TO THEM TO DECIDE
HOW AND WHEN TO EXECUTE.
>> I DON'T WOULDN'T TO LET YOU
GO WITHOUT ASKING ABOUT SUDAN.
ONE OF OUR REPORTERS WAS
ALONGSIDE SOME OF THE
EVACUATIONS FROM PORT SUDAN OF
AMERICANS.
SAMANTHA POWER TOLD KAITLIN ON
THE PROGRAM THAT THEY CANNOT GET
THE HUMANITARIAN AID THAT IS
NEEDED IN UNLESS THERE IS A
PERMANENT CEASEFIRE S THAT
ACHIEVABLE IN YOUR VIEW?
ALSO, CAN YOU GUARANTEE THAT
EVERY AMERICAN WHO WANTS TO GET
OUT OF SUDAN CAN?
>> SO ON THE FIRST QUESTION, IS
IT ACHIEVABLE?
WE CERTAINLY HOPE SO.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE WORKING
THROUGH DIPLOMACY TO GET THE
GENERALS TO PUT THEIR ARMS DOWN
AND TO ACTUALLY ABIDE BY THE
CEASEFIRES.
THE CEASEFIRES HAVE GONE THROUGH
A COUPLE OF EXTENSIONS HERE AND
RESULTED IN THE DECREASE OF THE
VIOLENCE BUT ELIMINATED IT.
IT NEEDS TO STOP SO THE
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE CAN GET
IN.
NOT JUST THE UNITED STATES WANTS
TO DO THIS.
U.S. AND ALLIED PARTNER
COUNTRIES WANT TO GET
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE IN,
FOOD, WATER MEDICINE IN CRITICAL
SHORT SUPPLY.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE GENERALS
IF THEY CARE ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
SUDAN AND THE SUDANESE PEOPLE TO
PUT ARMS DOWN AND LET THIS AID
AND ASSISTANCE GET IN.
CERTAINLY THE UNITED STATES WILL
BE THERE WITH THE PEOPLE OF
SUDAN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THAT -- THOSE
NECESSARY SUPPLIES.
NOW, AS FOR DEPARTURES, WE HAVE,
I THINK, AS YOU KNOW, CONDUCTED
THREE GROUND CONVOYS, GOTTEN OUT
ACCORDING TO TZ STATE DEPARTMENT
A THOUSAND AMERICANS.
WE STAY IN TOUCH WITH AMERICANS
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION THEY MAY
NEED SHOULD THEY STILL WANT TO
GET OUT.
I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT THE
POPULATION OF AMERICANS THAT WE
WERE IN TOUCH WITH, THAT WANTED
TO GET OUT, MUCH, MUCH SMALLER,
A FRACTION OF THAT NUMBER
FLOATING OUT THERE OF 16,000,
WHICH ARE DUAL NATIONALS WHO
WANT TO STAY IN THE COUNTRY,
THEY WERE BORN THERE, THEY LIVE
THERE, THAT HE WORK THERE, THEIR
FAMILIES ARE THERE, AND THEY
WANT TO STAY.
WE WILL STAY IN TOUCH WITH
AMERICANS AS NEEDED.
CONDUCTED THREE GROUND CONVOYS
TO GET AMERICANS OUT
SUCCESSFULLY AND THAT INCLUDES
EVEN YESTERDAY.
>> BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, I MEAN,
I THINK EVERY INTERVIEW WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION GOING ESPECIALLY
FROM A NATIONAL SECURITY
PERSPECTIVE WILL INCLUDE THIS
QUESTION, WHAT IS THE LATEST ON
THE EFFORTS TO GET EVAN
GERSHKOVICH OUT OF RUSSIA AS HE
IS BEING WRONGFULLY DETAINED?
HAVE YOU SPOKEN WITH RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS OR HIS FAMILY LATELY?
>> SECRETARY BLINKEN TALKED
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY.
WE ARE ACTIVELY, ENERGETICALLY
TRYING TO GET HIM RELEASED AS AL
AS PAUL WHALEN.
THAT HAS NEVER STOPPED.
THERE IS A PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE
FOR PAUL.
WE WILL URGE THE RUSSIANS TO
ACCEPT THAT PROPOSAL TO GET HIM
OUT OF THERE.
YES, WE ARE IN TOUCH WITH
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS AND TRYING TO
GET EVAN RELEASED.
WE WANT MORE CONSULAR ACCESS
WITH HIM.
WE HAVE ONLY HAD ONE VISIT.
WE WANT MORE ACCESS TO GET EYES
ON HIM, A CHANCE TO TALK TO HIM.
YES, WE ARE ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO SECURE HIS RELEASE.
>> THERE IS A PROPOSAL ON THE
TABLE FOR PAUL WHALEN.
WHAT ABOUT EVAN GERSHKOVICH?
>> WE ARE IN INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS TRYING TO GET THE
RUSSIANS TO AGREE TO RELEASE
HIM.
I WOULDN'T GO IN MORE DETAIL AT
THIS EARLY STAGE.
WE HAVE NOT, OBVIOUSLY,
FORGOTTEN EVAN.
WE HAVE CERTAINLY NOT FORGOTTEN
PAUL.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THESE
GENTLEMEN HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES
WHERE THEY BELONG.
>> FINALLY, AUSTIN TICE, WE
HEARD SECRETARY OF STATE ANTONY
BLINKEN SPEAKING ABOUT HIM AS
WELL YESTERDAY AND HE SAID THE
UNITED STATES IS ENGAGED WITH
SYRIA, WITH THIRD COUNTRIES AS
WELL.
WE BOTH IN WEEKEND AT THE WHITE
HOUSE CORRESPONDENTS' DINNER
TALK TO AUSTIN'S MOM.
FOR HER SAKE DOES THAT INDICATE
SHE SHE
OULD PE HER
SON WILL COME HOME AFTER 11
YEARS.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS NOT
FORGOTTEN HIM EITHER AND WE ARE
TRYING TO GET THE BEST
INFORMATION WE CAN ABOUT AUSTIN.
WE WANT TO SEE THIS ISSUE
RESOLVED.
WE WANT TO SEE HIM HOME AS WELL.
I HOPE THAT DEBRA CAN UNDERSTAND
HOW SERIOUSLY WE ARE TAKING HIS
DETENTION AS WELL AND TRYING TO
GET THIS RESOLVED